Coucou! Ça me fait plaisir de vous voir...
Bonjour !
J'adore les intros naturels.
Alors, aujourd'hui...
On va regarder Turkish Star Wars.
Il y a très peu de Star Wars dans le visuel...
Alors c'est pas très, oui...
Ça vous va ?
C'est magnifique.
De toute façon, vous avez pas le choix.
Bravo !
Ravie.
Je regrette déjà d'avoir accepté.
Ah pardon.
Ah oui d'accord.
Je vois le côté Star Wars.
Mais attendez mais on peut pas comprendre ce qu'il se passe si tout le monde parle.
Ah ça ressemble quand même beaucoup au Faucon Millenium.
Beaucoup à quoi ?
Au Faucon Millenium.
T'as jamais vu Star Wars ?
Moi, j'aime pas trop Star Wars.
T'aimes pas trop Star Wars ?!
Bah peut-être tu vas adorer.
Donc il y a plus, il y a plus de respect, quoi. On prend les images... C'est vraiment les mêmes.
Ça ressemble pas du tout à Twin Peaks.
C'est vrai que chaque sous-titre prend la moitié... Une phrase c'est...
8 lignes...
On est sûr que ça a un rapport avec Star Wars ?
Il y a un rapport juridique clairement.
Ah, si tout le truc se passe dans l'espace je vais faire la gueule parce que... Je déteste ça quoi !
Lolo, elle aime ni Star Wars ni les turques donc là...
Ça va être compliqué.
C'est Indiana Jones.
C'est la musique d'Indiana Jones.
Ah là c'est... Là, c'est plus Star Wars !
Là,on a du méchant de Tortues Ninja ça fait plaisir.
En même temps, les scènes d'avion dans Dunkerque, c'est pas si différent, hein.
Bah il y a Turkish Dunkerque d'ailleurs, qui existe.
Et je suis perdu.
C'était vraiment de la drague.
Le chanteur du Club Do, là.
Bernard Minet.
Mais oui ! C'est lui !
C'est la question qu'on se pose ?
Le fameux.
Oh putain !
Le fameux coup de sifflet !
Bah d'ailleurs, vous vous retenez actuellement de sauter sur l'écran.
N'y allez pas, n'y allez pas !
Franchement je mouille comme c'est pas possible !
Tu as mal sifflé !
Putain, il tape à côté !
C'est à s'y méprendre, hein.
Il est trop fort !
Oh ! Dynamique !
T'in, il est passé à ça de se prendre une tonne de cheval dans la gueule.
Non mais tu as vu comment il se...
Attends mais là ça me fait un peu peur.
Bah tu voulais du Twin Peaks, regarde on est pas loin, là.
Cette entrée de champ.
Il est bruyant ce feu derrière.
Une servante.
Non là il y a une bonne...
C'est chaud !
Attendez qu'il siffle !
Attendez qu'il siffle...
Ohlala, mais ses regards !
Oh ? C'était le pied ?
C'était le pied !
C'est bon tu nous vois, tu vois l'ombre là ?
C'est en boucle ?
Mais oui, c'est en boucle ce son.
Bon allez, ils sont tous morts !
Ah là, c'était pour de vrai, hein.
Lui, il s'est vraiment mangé le mur.
Qui c'est qui va encore faire des cauchemars cette nuit ?
C'est horrible.
Avec une musique de Happy End, quoi. Oui !
Vraiment !
Heureusement qu'on s'en est sorti. C'est exactement ça !
Menfin Hervé il y a quand même 57 enfants qui sont morts !
Là, il s'entraîne ! Non mais...
Depuis quand il a cette entrainement ?
J'adorerai quand...
Konan ! Un sourire ?
Oh un sourire putain !
C'est chaud !
Oui ou bien ?
Là, juste tu tapes dans le sable.
Le mec a tout compris, quoi. Il y a un côté 11 commandements, Michaël Youn: la course Teub.
Oui, un peu.
Oh putain ! Gentleman, le mec !
En même temps c'est assez noble.
Prenez en de la graine.
Oh non, prenez en de la graine, pas du tout. Ah moi, si quelqu'un me fait ça...
Du coup je fais la gueule, hein !
Ouais mais voilà, regarde !
T'in le mec il sait créer l'attente quoi.
Lui, en revanche, c'est vraiment mon personnage préféré.
Lui, il y a un Spin-off à faire là.
Ouais mais attends son pote à gauche, il a trop la classe.
118 218.
Moi je trouve que le héros est toujours très...
Il laisse peu transparaitre ses émotions à chaque fois. Ouais !
Mais parce qu'il est trop classe, il est trop fort.
Oh putain! Ça, c'est stylé !
Oh le deuxième !
Bah je... Si ah si !
Allez ! Le retour... Sans déconner !
C'est le meilleur moment du film !
Oh non là y'a trop...
Oh elle va mourir.
Oh la pauvre !
Ah Ça c'est badant !
Bah dis donc. Oh elle est devenue une araignée.
Alors d'une manière...
Mais il ne... Il ne le touche pas ! Mais oui !
Ouais parce que... Mais je comprends pas !
C'est parce que c'est un héros !
Un seul coup décisif c'est propre !
Ah, un bruit de chiotte.
Un bruit de chasse d'eau.
En fait, il est au milieu parce que...
Très bon monstre !
Il a mis juste des yeux dans une pierre.
Sur les fétichistes, il y a des mecs qui sont habillés comme ça.
On voit pas mais il y a une laisse reliée à un gars comme as.
Ça, c'est un plan volé aussi. De Astérix Mission Cléopâtre.
C'est une autre culture.
Non !
C'est quoi ce rebond ?
Mais attendez, l'ami il était entrain de se battre et là, il est là.
Mais c'était l'ami qui se battait, là ?!
Oui bah nous engueule pas ! On comprend pas non plus.
On comprend pas non plus !
Tu nous parles comme si on avait suivi bah ...
Dis-leur que je les aime toutes !
Quoi ? quand tu dis toutes, c'est toutes toutes ?!
Ça peut, parce que ça pourrait prendre du temps. Toutes !
Ok.
Ah il suffisait de faire un...
un feu dans une poubelle en fait, pour la détruire, ça va.
Ah elle a fondu, elle a fondu. Mais non !
Ah du coup, il va s'investir du pouvoir de l'épée. Oh la vache !
Bah vous savez quoi ? C'est pas si mal.
Ah ! Il a fait les pieds en scred !
Je pense il a fait sa teub aussi ! Bah il est obligé.
Franchement la question se pose.
Ah le pied ça fait ça ?! Ah ouais ouais.
Attends...
Ah c'est des effets, alors ça pour la petite histoire, c'est fait directement sur la pellicule.
Oui, c'est gratté. Oui.
Il gratte la pellicule pour faire les lasers. C'est vrai ?
C'est trop classe. Je te jure.
Il fait vraiment du trampoline là, c'est fini là !
Là, il fait juste du trampoline.
Les gars attends...
C'est.. Regarde ! Shurikens géantes !
Bah il a des shurikens géants et l'étoile de David.
J'adore.
Le foot c'est génial.
Ah bah là ouais !
Ah ouais. Ohlala.
Allez !
La technique des trous de nez !
Il a été fendu en deux.
Non ? Ouais.
T'in c'est pas mal.
Ça, en turc, ça veut dire fin.
J'aime bien.
Bravo !
C'est un film sur la paix. La paix...
Et les relations hétérosexuelles.
Non mais c'était, c'est très positif.
Franchement, personne n'a dormi déjà.
Non, on a pas dormi.
Mais en même temps on peut pas... Oui on arrête pas de parler...
Elle est très premier degré.
Merci d'être venu. Bah attends Julien... Mais merci à toi.
La prochaine fois je réinvite la même équipe...
On va voir un film encore plus long et plus complexe. Ah ça me va.
Ça vous va ? Et n'hésite pas à nous voler une autre heure et demie...
Avec une énorme merde !